hello and welcome to another somewhat
shorter session
see get a three plus two game
I think if I'm not um
Spector's plink sound doesn't happen if
I just go for the regular three plus two
the the standard button I'm just getting
the games a lot quicker
so I'm going for that even though um
sometimes
them
Holland's reading is a bit lower
yeah this is a line that indefinitely
to check again that I have in my my
default book but I keep forgetting the
lines and I'm always working on new
stuff I'm not really repeating my old
order let's say a repertoire
after Knight e4 Bishop e5 and white his
chances for a small advantage it depends
a little bit how black continues right
after
I think e 6 was more of that name
also analyzed for the book
I mean yeah this is cheating but I could
I could look it up I don't want to do
that okay now let's see what rise like a
phoenix is doing
yeah it takes quite a while
which is not a surprise the whole line
is basically new c3 was never analyzed
in any publication as far as I'm aware
if it happened I didn't see it let's say
when I wrote the book
what is that
that's a bit long I mean it's increment
but still maybe something happened on
his side
or me not
the mailman the hits a Sunday the day
I'm recording this okay now he finally
captures
I guess one
you
the problem of this position is that the
bishop mb7
is just not good
it's not a good piece
Wow it's taking ages
what about d6
it could be a thing but
yeah let's just develop
okay so he's accepting that backward
porn now with six you can you can fight
the pawn
in the in such a weak spot this is an
interesting moment because Knight b6
is kind of threatening
a six
you
mm interesting
you
maybe I should just try to revoke his
rook to b8 so that the knight cannot
move and then go here it's a bit odd but
now the knight cannot move
you
and the absolutely wants to move the
night
now I can take on d7 and play Bishop h6
for a simple solution - to this position
it would definitely be a better better
position for white as the bishop stays a
problem piece and I get to trade his
best piece on g7
so I'm going to capture and now I need
to increase the pressure on the e-file
probably Hokie three
it can move the e-pawn it's not losing
material but
yes so I need to take
but the resulting position is definitely
yeah
midweek with week so look deep one
hmm
yeah I did not really appreciate the
smooth
or that would weaken too much but
was far too general
far2 general assessment
Knights b5 I'm thinking about Luke age 3
ultimately
you
not sure how much of a threat that
really is but he's got 15 seconds this
is not exactly fun to defend with no
time on the clock so he allowed the
check only not much that he could have
done there
so the check he has to go kingi 890 XG 6
it's almost winning
not quite
almost
I can play at night see seven down
if I take now in h8 king of seven
and 97 is kind of a shocker move but I
know if it takes it
you
no don't find a win that is a shame
yeah 97 doesn't quite work it's the
problem
[Music]
you
I have a strategic advantage here but
not not something
not something amazing
as I once had I think I had a very nice
position at one point
I overlooked animals
you
blundered c-form are badly played
you
man I didn't
that one that he has the check first
that's a bit of a pain
you
Jesus
you
I'm losing this game this is such a such
a terrible play
unbelievable really
you
that's all
and it was probably like a +3 or
something and many points
it's actually crazy that I don't have a
killer here I mean this is really really
really close to complete disaster
many things are very close here and I
mean besides the fact that such a
position here she's terrible but
Oh came so night b5 Queen e7 is hanging
by a thread here really
but the position that I got was also
really really good I mean this is very
good for white
I just didn't didn't find any
coordination here I mean you just have
to look at the pawn structure form an
assessment ok nightie 2 is very strong
actually just kicking the rook out and
then play Ruby 3 such a position is more
or less winning but no way it went it
also wasn't bad I can even take on d5
here I didn't want to because I kind of
always felt I cannot take because ii
takes and that blunder the rook so I can
just take for a huge advantage I didn't
see that instead i blundered disc and of
course I should draw this ending but I
mean I'm better here but I I should not
lose it this is the thing I actually
wanted to play f4 here but then I
recognize that it's just weakening to
tooth too much and here I didn't see
that he has a check first so I should
just go back to e1 and that I can also
never lose of course just so awful
and this is already tricky because the
see point is dangerous and with seconds
on the clock this is much easier for
black to play because you know what you
do you just push you're free in porn
that's terrible
never lose this game
I mean I also was like two and a half
minutes up on the clock
after he played this bad opening
you
I'm pretty awful
okay
it is just good for black
pretty awful version of the advanced
CARICOM
I've got extra Tempe on the car oh and
white has problems with this pin
okay
you
don't mind the trade
of course you take with the F pawn
getting the rook open
much better than H pawn
as it often is they are taking away from
the center is very often the best option
if you open up a file for work
I'm ready to go to see forum
I need to check that I'm not playing
quickly after a game like the one before
I'm always slightly untilled because you
just just just the game that I lost it's
not a game that the opponent won like
you're better forever and then you play
something incredibly erotic and lose
now this is however fairly easy to play
position I have there our post on c4
white cannot play B 3 because a3 is
hanging and the simple plan is to just
double on the C file and then start to
and then then I get then I got threats
yeah something like night a3 and so on
those two points they they stop f5 very
reliably he's still trying to play it so
I should have a look at them yeah but I
don't see how it should work
I mean if he plays a5 I take twice I
even have g6 then
I'm just a bit weak on the d5 pawn
five
I can take one a three know him let's do
that
you
mom's really going hard for f5
now I could just go back right
nothing wrong about that after pawn
takes I can still take on c3
and f5 I mean there's all nice good but
also his King is pretty much open
my next move is probably just to get
back with the night or back yeah no it's
a text so I have to go back
he's again trying to play a five
should do this
being ready to just take the night
that is after this scenario
on d5 is a bit less of an issue if I
take c3 now it probably takes is 6
that is a bit of a problem so I'm going
to take first
you
yeah okay five I'm going to check on g6
and then trade on f5 then take on c3 so
I have to take this first
now I take on c3
naturally dangerous night
now the check
we go somewhere on the edge file
how do we convert
one way could be queen a form just going
for
we nee for going for Queen a to check
it's their counter click we never three
I go Quincy to check
should be enough
I mean if for what a system will clean
you - maybe
have to be a little bit cautious to not
not go too far away from my own king
not certain what I should do after
Queenie for Queenie to
[Music]
we a one these kind of moves can be too
loose
we have to h6 mmm not sure about all
this
but I don't really see what else to do
those air snore sound for the more sense
it rotating
see that idea in the first place
or let's say check
it also looks strange honestly
so now aged six the bishop cannot move
yes ooh check
I'm still winning a piece
I also have a move like 22 or 92
or the check
we need to is the safest move I guess
come on let's do this I feel I feel like
that could be something bad still
happening it's remaking so this is just
trading the Queen's off
you
he more or less has to take Wow
really
then what
I don't understand us okay I have to
take anyway it's the only more ah shoot
in C let's move at all
yes check on c8
oli Molly oh shoot
I screwed the sample I cannot believe
that I screwed this up unbelievable I'm
getting checkmated now that's crazy
that's really crazy
unbelievable like every move was winning
really literally every move probably in
this position is winning
No
ninety-two windscreen a one winch sh6
wins this doesn't win look f8 and he
finds this I mean okay he has to find it
because everything else is just
completely lost
so I basically forced him to win after
this come on sorry I sometimes get into
these rents because this is a game where
like you it was essentially over by here
right you just have to be a little bit
precise just a little bit and yeah I
wasn't so here yeah you can do whatever
yeah even look g6 is probably not the
best move because it makes things too
complicated you can play Queen e6 root
CA just cover everything I mean this is
a completely dead piece on a three ah
great session here no wonder that I'm
not getting to 2600 here I'm gifting
away those many points it's really
terrible
[Music]
okay then I have to win this one
Jim how do we win him the recursion is a
bit sharper than the BOGO
yeah it doesn't really matter because
like normally I'm out playing the
opponent anyway and then I'm killing
myself it's just like the typical
scenario
[Music]
it's a bit of a strange move order here
you
so let's tickle tickle him a little bit
it's a bit bit odd
I probably made some move or a mistake
Oh Kim it's not the end of the world but
it looks a little bit strange
you
yeah probably
trade this
and also get the night away from c6 now
we have a fairly normal cards but
you
okay now I can play
and one way to handle this
five I think I'm going with this you
probably not trade probably will go back
but then it doesn't have you could be
one he loves the trade okay
this should be entirely innocuous
so might give us 36
you
yeah this is
but 101 if you get every Bishop traded
and you have two nights as black you are
doing okay
white is not managing b5 he might be
able to
yeah no one probably not like sacrifice
on b7 but this is probably just
incorrect
one negative point about my position is
that I cannot easily move the f-pawn
that's slightly slightly off-putting
you
we cost 96 but I still have to have to
play of success no way around that
after pushes night back even though it
is a slide weakening
okay
um okay if I go to c4 or it takes Knight
takes he has a four at the end
so maybe I should better go to c8
and want to keep reform
picture
you
queenside is completely frozen nothing
much happening there
now we cannot take the night
you
so you want to go if you are not quite
sure about it
okay
and always go to g5
okay now f5 is an interesting move
to get to the pawn Knight e5 I just take
the pawn
let's try to wind upon
yeah the night on b6 is on a very
mysterious I was looking forward journey
you don't quite know where it's going
yeah now you can you can certainly trade
but
now chief is also pretty attempting
you
and now how do we how do we finish this
before
retina f/4
you
if he takes it
I'm sorry details should be killing
it takes a look I mean
okay
I work c5 okay
you
definitely am as I didn't see that
okay and now the problem starts white
was completely killed in this game and
now I have to still be precise and that
often is not what I can do
now pawn takes rook c5 awkward
I didn't need to sacrifice the exchange
I mean I was just a pawn up and win with
whatever but
this oversight was very annoying and now
he starts um he and Mary counterclaim
[Music]
I only have 20-something seconds but I'm
winning so much material here back
but really really win
I want to give him any past pawn or
whatnot
so now I'm a bunch of pawns up
three doesn't yet win
think I need I need the rook active
rupee seven walk CAS my idea
you
you know the last two games really have
shaken my confidence yeah I'm looking
I'm checking everything three times
I think that
be the end of it
not the end
now ah I didn't see the check No
now I still have to play a bloody
endgame
ah
you
unbelievable it's really unbelievable
you
you
you
yeah I was just I was just going going
for the pawns I didn't really look at
anything else
again a check and he goes to be one come
on
okay
you
for a moment I thought I was losing on
time yes I was just so bad I mean like I
couldn't just display normal stuff
they're like here it's like everything
f4 is actually the best move because I
can take with the pawn okay I was just
so irritated by rook c5 I just have g5 I
completely missed that one it would have
been completely devastating
I mean I've been taking with everything
and he cannot move the night that's just
going to be made yeah yeah a very
instructive thing is dead after he
allows the trade here and I get the
night 26 I'm perfectly fine and this is
actually and this evaluation by the
engine is actually a little bit too
friendly for Wyatt because now I can do
absolutely nothing in this position I'm
freezing the queenside
and long-term I can do stuff on the
kingside so if the engine gives a solid
ride for why this is just not true um
yeah
like here this is definitely very fine
for me not that nothing can happen
basically the queenside nothing happens
and he played it he played it badly and
gave me that pawn on no particular
reason he could have played ya Knight f4
or something a here and here it's over
because Knight is misplaced on b6 his
t-shirt is probably um here focus on
keeping their pawn
okay so let's go for one more game maybe
I can
never the score
a bit of a shaky session really
get a game
you
so disorder
they slightly off
you
an almost team of that until the point
where somebody takes on C form
you
yeah here b5 is actually good
oh that is an interesting moment because
v6 is also pretty good
taking is the more natural thing
probably but b6 is also a strong move so
let's do this
you
ideas to play g4 and Bishop f1
so the bishop has a good retreat square
ready
some will probably play 92
pretty soon trying to get the night to a
five this is the
dream scenario
it's interesting hmm interesting waiter
to counterplay him
you
I think taking is probably the easiest
thing to do
I should probably take with the piece
or takes that that looks extremely
passive
you know and now I want to keep my
bishop on that diagonal so I have to
probably retreat it because an f4 is
unprotected
yeah that looks like a good news
se5
mmm
the experiment to play b6 did not really
not dead well
III is taking c3 and plays Bishop reform
you
let's not actually
nice I don't quite know what to do
you
Oh
you
yeah it's just not a good position
interesting
I mean I knew that taking on c6 is
better than b6
but I thought b6 also interesting to try
but it's probably too slow only too slow
he can take now on c3 and possibly go we
should reform possibly is a weird way to
put it evil people do that as I guess no
he doesn't
you
[Music]
you
and it was a bad idea
ruk g1 you can actually take on f3 and
then
I have had and then moved to Bishop f6
Bishop
you
old
ouch
you
died I was I go I got completely
outplayed in this game
naive and
you
and I didn't expect that one
I thought you should have something
better in that same
but black is still of course better
[Music]
you
you know I think he had he had something
better than this but it's still still
not a good position he is friend look I
have seven I had it I knew why I wanted
to play Bishop reform and then I forgot
about it what a lousy session of chess
[Laughter]
my god
you
maybe I can
Kim now I'm actually getting some
counterplay
you
I talked about the lucky break
you
let's see it's not actually easy to
enter
you
and need
look 27 at the end
young still
exactly an easy win
oh really not you who take it
thought he had to take it
still not promoting it easily
not at all actually my god what a
terrible game I'm really playing it's
like a complete idiot
amazing
amazing
you
my chance to win ders are zero like just
zero
you would have to do something really
stupid
ooh to lose
and I could lose well if I'm
playing
[Music]
way up late before
you
he wants to get the bishop to g3 I guess
it I just take g7
Wow I must be completely crazy I need to
I need to just stop this I have to stop
after this session I'm playing like a
complete madman
okay there was a final game for today I
was just too terrible what am I doing
here
I mean I probably should eat something
that that would help but rook takes xi7
what I was just anticipating this move
and take next and I just took it instead
I could take h4 actually
which is okay silly draw but what kind
of a game was that and why am I not
winning here right so I take bishop
takes
it's just a lyric see one is fairly
easier
you
and here should win somehow itís just
don't believe it
though I should bring the king of Ruby
eight was completely nonsensical
and now this is just I mean what did I
expect to happen
it was a crazy session
now I can be lucky here that he didn't
take the rook on g7
let's end this thanks a lot for watching